[MUSIC PLAYING]
So constraints.
They're a great way for
you, as a developer,
to deal with the ever expanding
number of screen sizes, device
rotations, and new
form factors like slide
over in the iOS world.
But one unfortunate casualty
in this brave new world
of alignment has been
the way we animate views.
See, it used to be, we could
go around setting a UI views
position or frame with
a fun little UI view
animate with duration
method and watch our views
scoot around the screen.
That was fun.
But that's harder to do in
a world full of constraints.
Constraints don't
necessarily play nicely
with a view whose frame
you're setting explicitly,
as you can see here.
Well, that leads us to
this episodes quick tip,
sent in by Jacob Cho,
a fan of Route 85
and a software engineer
at Ensemble, a mobile app
developer located in beautiful
Vancouver, British Columbia.
Jacob notes that many
iOS developers forget
that, in addition to the old way
of animating a view's position,
you can also animate
constraints in iOS.
Let's look at how
you might do that.
Here's my storyboard
and, as you can see here,
I've got everything set up
nicely using constraints.
Now, to move my UI image
view on and offscreen,
I'm going to want to change
this constraint here,
the one that sets my images
leading edge to the leading
edge of my super view.
Right now, it's set to minus
180, so it's off screen.
So first I'm going to control
drag from this constraint
into my view controller, to
make it an IB outlet of type NS
layout constraint.
This allows me to
access it in my code.
Now I can adjust
it with a standard
UIView.animateWithDuration call.
In this case, I'll change the
constant of the constraint
from minus 180 to 0, so
that it appears on screen.
And now we can give it a try.
Huh, that's weird.
The constant definitely
changed but what
happened to my animation?
Well, it turns out, to get this
constant to animate nicely,
I need to call layoutIfNeeded
on my view controller's view,
within this animation block.
We'll give it one more and,
oh, that's much better.
I now have a constraint that I
can change within an animation
block and everything animates
smoothly to its final position,
except in cases where
I want to adjust
something besides my
constraint's constant.
Let's take a look
at another example.
Here, I want to adjust
this center square
to expand or shrink to
be either twice or half
the width of its neighbors.
Now I could do that, in theory,
by adjusting the multiplier
on the center views
with constraint.
But it turns out that changing
that multiplier in code
doesn't work.
See, constraint multipliers
are a get only property,
and Xcode will give me an error.
So how do I change it?
Well, the answer is I don't.
Instead, I create two
completely different constraints
and enable or disable
either one as necessary.
As long as I'm still calling
layoutIfNeeded in my animation
block, this kind of
change will still animate.
Now, there are two
ways I can accomplish
this constraint swapping.
One way is to create
both constraints
in Interface Builder, like so.
Now Xcode will complain
that these are incompatible,
and it's right.
So first step, we'll
uninstall one of them
by checking this box here.
Next, we'll control drag
both of these constraints
into our code to
make them IB outlets.
And then I can enable or
disable these, as necessary,
in my animation
block, like this.
Once again, you'll
notice I make sure we're
calling layoutIfNeeded
in our animation block
and we end up with a nice,
smooth looking animation.
Look at that.
The other way to
accomplish this would
be to create a completely
new constraint in code.
This is useful when I
don't know in advance
what I'm going to want
this multiplier to be
and I need to create
it dynamically.
So let's see that in action.
This time in my animation
block, I'll first
remove the old constraint.
Next up, I can create
a new multiplier.
Let's make it slightly
random, just for fun.
Oh, hey, that is fun.
OK, next I'll create
a brand new constraint
with this new multiplier and
assign it to my center view
with property.
And then it can add it
back in again to my view.
Finally, I call layoutIfNeeded
on this super view
in the animation
block and I once again
have some nicely animating views
that use this new constraint
that I've created.
And because this is all
done using constraints,
you'll notice this works
as intended on an iPhone,
an iPhone in landscape
mode, or even, say,
a slide overview on an iPad.
And once you understand
that this trick simply
involves removing
an old constraint
and adding a new one,
you might discover
a whole new world of
animation is available to you,
simply by turning on and
off various constraints.
For example, on this screen,
I can change all my views
to be either left
aligned or right aligned,
simply by adding and
removing two different groups
of constraints and
then calling our now
familiar layoutIfNeeded method.
Pretty neat, huh?
Oh by the way, one fun
little quirk about all this.
If you add your new constraints
before you remove the old ones,
iOS will complain about all
the incompatible constraints
it has to deal with in
those like few milliseconds.
So always make sure you
remove the old ones first
before adding the new ones.
So thanks to Jacob
for the quick tip.
Jacob, you're going to get a
very stylish Google t-shirt
in the mail, but hang on.
We're not done yet.
You see, now that you know all
about constraint animation,
I have a couple more quick tips
from one of Google's engineers
about more efficient
ways to implement it.
So follow me onto
the next video,
because we're not done
learning just yet.
Click here, click here.
And, otherwise, I'll
see you on Route 85.
Bye.
[MUSIC PLAYING]